[Music]
and that's why i'm going to direct this
verdict and find this here defend it
guilty
god
alistair that was terrific terrific
bloody genius you're not going to top
that one wouldn't be the first time i've
had the clap
[Applause]
marina
you ghosted me well i ghosted everybody
look i'm here on business alistair pinch
the after killed his wife
maybe he killed her maybe he didn't i
don't think he even knows that guy's a
blackout drunk i deplore drinking alone
so i have a devil
the network's got a lot riding on him mr
waldo you're looking to hire apis i'm
retired come on let me bring you back
into the real world what would i even do
with the money where's all your stuff
calm myself down to 100 things
and you kept that hat
what save detective will you return to
your mountain and leave me to the fates
will you stick around long enough to see
the police maybe get it right this time
[Music]
where did you come from welcome to
kindergartens of the rich and famous
deathness has shot the hell out of this
place huh come meet me tonight we can
talk then
do you trust me why should i trust you
so anything you're not remembering
allister i had gotten married fathered
children have taken out mortgages and
not remembered
you do realize that everyone is
[Music]
oh god officer they're gonna arrest you
go put some clothes on don't be silly
enough the network will adore me in this
wardrobe
anyway
if it's good enough for wacko jacko it's
good enough for me
can't you tell when a girl just wants to
have a drink with you
buckle up
[Music]
okay look i'm a pacifist and i refuse to
get involved
have you had enough
i've had enough
[Music]
you